[Music]
here I want to discuss one common type
of problem where integration comes up
finding the average of a continuous
variable this is a perfectly useful
thing to know in its own right but
what's really neat is that it can give
us a completely different perspective
for why integrals and derivatives are
inverses of each other to start take a
look at the graph of sine of X between 0
and PI which is half of its period what
is the average height of this graph on
that interval it's not a useless
question all sorts of cyclic phenomena
in the world are modeled using sine
waves for example the number of hours
that the Sun is up per day as a function
of what day of the year it is follows a
sine wave pattern so if you wanted to
predict say the average effectiveness of
solar panels in summer months versus
winter months you'd want to be able to
answer a question like this what is the
average value of that sine function over
half of its period whereas a case like
this is going to have all sorts of
constants mucking up the function you
and I are just going to focus on a pure
unencumbered sine of X function but the
substance of the approach would be
totally the same in any other
application it's kind of a weird
question to think about though isn't it
the average of a continuous variable
usually with averages we think of a
finite number of variables where you can
add them all up and divide that sum by
how many there are
but there are infinitely many values of
sine of X between 0 and pi and it's not
like we can just add up all of those
numbers and divide by infinity now this
sensation actually comes up a lot in
math and it's worth remembering where
you have this vague sense that what you
want to do is add together infinitely
many values associated with a continuum
even though that doesn't really make
sense and almost always when you get
that sense the key is going to be to use
an integral somehow and to think through
exactly how a good first step is usually
to just approximate your situation with
some kind of finite sum in this case
imagine sampling a finite number of
points evenly spaced along this range
since it's a finite sample you can find
the average by just adding up all of the
heights sine of X at each one of these
and then dividing that sum by the number
of points that you sampled right and
presumably if the idea of an average
height among all infinitely many points
is going to make any sense at all the
more points we sample which would
involve adding up more and more heights
the closer the average of that sample
should be to the actual average of the
continuous variable and this should feel
at least somewhat related to taking an
integral of sine of X between 0 and PI
even if it might not be exactly clear
how the two ideas match up for that
integral remember you also think of a
sample of inputs on this continuum but
instead of adding the height sine of X
at each one and dividing by how many
there are you add up sine of x times DX
where DX is the spacing between the
samples that is you're adding up little
areas not Heights and technically the
integral is not quite this sum it's
whatever that sum approaches as DX
approaches 0 but it is actually quite
helpful to reason with respect to one of
these finite iterations where we're
looking at a concrete size for DX and
some specific number of rectangles so
what you want to do here is reframe this
expression for the average this sum of
the heights divided by the number of
sample points in terms of DX the spacing
between sin
apples and now if I tell you that the
spacing between these points is say zero
point one and you know that they range
from zero to pi can you tell me how many
there are
well you can take the length of that
interval pi and divide it by the length
of the space between each sample if it
doesn't go in perfectly evenly you would
have to round down to the nearest
integer but as an approximation this is
completely fine so if we write that
spacing between samples as DX the number
of samples is pi divided by DX and when
we substitute that into our expression
up here you can rearrange it putting
that DX up top and distributing it into
the sum but think about what it means to
distribute that DX up top it means that
the terms you're adding up will look
like sine of X times DX
for the various inputs X that you're
sampling so that numerator looks exactly
like an integral expression and so for
larger and larger samples of points this
average will approach the actual
integral of sine of X between 0 and PI
all divided by the length of that
interval pi in other words the average
height of this graph is this area
divided by its width on an intuitive
level and just thinking in terms of
units that feels pretty reasonable
doesn't it area divided by width gives
you an average height so with this
expression in hand let's actually solve
it as we saw last video to compute an
integral you need to find an
antiderivative of the function inside
the integral some other function whose
derivative is sine of X and if you're
comfortable with derivatives of trig
functions you know that the derivative
of cosine is negative sine so if you
just negate that negative cosine is the
function we want the antiderivative of
sine and to go check yourself on that
look at this graph of negative cosine at
0 the slope is 0 and then it increases
up to some maximum slope at PI halves
and then goes back down to zero at PI
and in general its slope does indeed
seem to match the height of the sine
graph at every point so what do we have
to do to evaluate the integral of sine
between 0 and pi
well we evaluate this antiderivative at
the upper bound and subtract off its
value at the lower bound more visually
that is the difference in the height of
this negative cosine graph above pi and
its height at 0 and as you can see that
change in height is exactly 2 that's
kind of interesting isn't it that the
area under this sine graph turns out to
be exactly 2 so the answer to our
average-height problem this integral
divided by the width of the region
evidently turns out to be 2 divided by
pi which is around 0.6 for
I promised at the start that this
question of finding the average of a
function offers an alternate perspective
on why integrals and derivatives are
inverses of each other why the area
under one graph has anything to do with
the slope of another graph notice how
finding this average value two divided
by pi came down to looking at the change
in the antiderivative negative cosine x
over the input range divided by the
length of that range and another way to
think about that fraction is as the rise
over run slope between the point of the
antiderivative graph below 0 and the
point of that graph above pi and now
think about why it might make sense that
this slope would represent an average
value of sine of X on that region well
by definition sine of X is the
derivative of this antiderivative graph
it gives us the slope of negative cosine
at every point so another way to think
about the average value of sine of X is
as the average slope over all tangent
lines here between 0 and pi and when you
view things like that doesn't it make a
lot of sense that the average slope of a
graph over all of its points in a
certain range should equal the total
slope between the start and end points
to digest this idea it helps to think
about what it looks like for a general
function for any function f of X if you
want to find its average value on some
interval say between a and B what you do
is take the integral of f on that
interval divided by the width of that
interval B minus a you can think of this
as the area under the graph divided by
its width or more accurately it is the
signed area of that graph since any area
below the x-axis is counted as negative
and it's worth taking a moment to
remember what this area has to do with
the usual notion of a finite average
where you add up many numbers and divide
by how many there are when you take some
sample of points spaced out by DX the
number of samples is about equal to the
length of the interval divided by DX so
if you add up the values of f of X at
each sample and divide by the total
number of samples it's the same as
adding up the product f of x times DX
and dividing by the width of the entire
interval the only difference between
that and the integrals is that the
integral asks what happens as DX
approaches 0 but that just corresponds
with samples of more and more points
that approximate the true average
increasingly well now for any integral
evaluating it comes down to finding an
antiderivative of f of X commonly
denoted capital f of X
what we want is the change to this
antiderivative between a and B capital F
of B minus capital F of a which you can
think of as the change in height of this
new graph between the two bounds
I've conveniently chosen an
antiderivative that passes through zero
at the lower bound here but keep in mind
you can freely shift this up and down
adding whatever constant you want to it
and it would still be a valid
antiderivative so the solution to the
average problem is the change in the
height of this new graph divided by the
change to the x-value between a and B in
other words it is the slope of the
antiderivative graph between the two
endpoints and again when you stop to
think about it that should make a lot of
sense because little f of X gives us the
slope of the tangent line to this graph
at each point after all it is by
definition the derivative of capital F
so why are anti-derivatives the key to
solving integrals well my favorite
intuition is still the one that I showed
last video but a second perspective is
that when you reframe the question of
finding an average of a continuous value
as instead finding the average slope of
a bunch of tangent lines it lets you see
the answer just by comparing endpoints
rather than having to actually tally up
all of the points in between in the last
video I described a sensation that
should bring integrals to your mind
namely if you feel like the problem
you're solving could be approximated by
breaking it up somehow and adding up a
large number of small things and here I
want you to come away recognizing a
second sensation that should also bring
integrals to your mind if ever there's
some idea that you understand in a
finite context and which involves adding
up multiple values like taking the
average of a bunch of numbers and if you
want to generalize that idea to apply to
an infinite continuous range of values
try seeing if you can phrase things in
terms of an integral it's a feeling that
comes up all the time especially in
probability and it's definitely worth
remembering my thanks as always go to
those making these videos possible
[Music]
you
[Music]